foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI there's some big news
for us girls in football the fa have
made some exciting changes but is it
enough
and I find out how martial arts can
kick-start our Mental Health
all right
welcome to FYI where we bring you all
the latest news on all the big stories
you may have had a lot of talk recently
about teacher strikes and you may have
even been affected by them thousands of
schools face disruption as teachers go
on strike over their pay
like many other workers teachers believe
they should be getting paid more as food
clothes electricity gas and petrol have
become more expensive however the
government which controls their wages
say they cannot afford their demands in
February there was the biggest day of
strikes in 10 years when more than 500
000 teachers train drivers bus drivers
lecturers and many more people refuse to
come into work in what was called
walkout Wednesday
tens of thousands of teachers have now
gone on strike causing schools to close
and pupils to be stuck at home here at
FYI we've discussed teacher strikes with
the education secretary Jillian Keegan
and the leader of the labor party
sakiastava but what do schools have to
say we went to an FYI News Club at
casterton College in Stamford where two
pupils quiz their teacher on the strikes
[Music]
so why are teachers going on strike
mostly because the government is not
really giving teachers pay that reflects
how passionate we are about the job that
we do they don't want to be on strike
but I know they feel horrible about it
because it has an effect on you how do
you think it does impact our education
well I mean there's obviously going to
be a few hours of any subject that you
lose and you are going to feel behind
because of it that's the same for
schools up and down the country how do
you feel about the teachers going on
strike it's one or two days off but that
day I missed out on maths geography
history French which I really need to
improve at do you think striking is the
best way to get what you want no but
strikes are the last part of asking for
what we want and it's actually a formal
process the government set rules for
going on strike and everything needs to
be done before that so no it's it's not
the best way but it is the last way you
know teachers who work very very hard
and don't feel very happy about the the
money they're receiving or the the
funding their scores getting might be
terribly cross and stressed and and not
be as happy and bright and cheery about
their work and I just wondered whether
you'd ever noticed any of your teachers
feeling a little bit or looking a bit
burnt out or little bit
upset at times I feel very passionately
that the school needs funding and
teachers need to feel satisfied that
they are being respected in a way that
makes the difference to what we do
if you have a story and want to report
an FYI get in touch via our webpage or
even better get your teacher to set up
an FYI News Club at your school members
can get the chance to report for us
we'll even help you film your story and
you can watch and discuss the latest
episodes of free resources every week
[Music]
so are you looking forward to Eurovision
yeah yeah I can't wait for it really
it's exciting I mean have you seen the
UK entry this year yeah it seems very
catchy though yeah it's really catchy I
really hope we win now are you getting
excited for the Eurovision song contest
I definitely am because this year for
the first time in 25 years the
competition will be hosted by the UK the
massive event will take place in
Liverpool where 37 countries will sing
their hearts out in a bid to win the
competition
and since it's been running since 1956
we thought we'd bring you up to speed
with some top Eurovision facts
the most famous Eurovision winner has to
be the Swedish band Abba who won the
competition in 1974 with their hit
single Waterloo they went on to become
one of the most successful pop groups
ever selling nearly 400 million records
worldwide
the contest has had five Barefoot
singers take the title
Ireland still holds the record for the
most victories in the competition
they've won the contest seven times and
they also have the rare success of
winning three consecutive years in a row
Australia can take part in the
Eurovision song contest despite not even
being in Europe they were first granted
entry in 2015 as a gesture of Goodwill
and even came second in 2016.
this year's UK Eurovision entry May
Muller once starred in singer Mika's
music video for his single Grace Kelly
when she was just nine years old
[Music]
recently it was announced that schools
will receive a whopping 600 million
pounds in funding from the government to
help girls get better access to sport at
school result yeah it's all come about
because England's women's football team
wrote an open letter to the government
asking them to make football more
accessible to the millions of girls
across the country who've been inspired
to take up the sport after the lionesses
win in the Euros in 2022 and it's not
just the government who've been getting
involved the Football Association and
the Premier League have both created new
schemes to help girls get better
football training and with all this new
training the next generation of
lionesses could be running around our
playgrounds right now and no one shares
that dream more than FYI viewer and
football fanatic Ellie
[Music]
more than 700 000 girls play football
regularly in England this number has
risen massively in the past couple of
years especially with the women's team
winning the Euros recently
but there still has not been in our
support for girls in football a report
showed that less than half a secondary
schools provide equal lessons in
football for both boys and girls
the Football Association the fa has
exciting new plans to help us girls who
love football get better coaching there
will be special centers set up all over
the country to help girls between 8 and
16 years old become better players
there is going to be 70 of these
emerging Talent centers in England this
means if you're a talented footballer
there is more opportunities to play
football professionally the Premier
League is also helping by giving money
to hire more coaches to work with girls
so if you're a football this is great
news but what else newspapers on to help
girls play football I'm here in my club
to ask some of my teammates so I feel
like boys get more like support off
people and if you like girls you need to
like get the same as boys do we'll
always be put seconds there's not enough
girls like facilities at toilets and
stuff clubs they should have like a
training facility so that there's a home
team and the waiting changing room not
many like clubs and Brands want to
sponsor us as much as the boys teams
with better sponsors and Facilities than
like there's more transfers becoming
better professional footballers Boys
football teams get more games than girls
like we've only
I think one tournament we need to get
more girls into football and get more
girls games going on so the fa have made
a great step in the right direction but
like my teammates say this still is more
to be done
because of our last program Refugee
Arvin hit the headlines after he quit
circus armor and what labor would do to
help refugees arrive safely in the UK
Mr Stone the government says that they
want to work with the French authorities
to stop people reaching the UK on a boat
like my family did but what about
working with a friend start providing
Seafood to the UK for genuine refugees
like me
would you do that
oven is an Iranian Refugee who reached
the UK with his family on a small boat
run by illegal people Smugglers the
journey was very dangerous and they
nearly drowned
it's Journeys like this that the
government's trying to stop with its new
immigration plans but what's this all
got to do with ex-footballer Gary
lineker where we've been investigating
recently the football presenter made
comments on social media criticizing the
government's new immigration plans the
BBC said his comments went against their
company guidelines and removed Gary from
presenting much of the day
some other BBC Sports presenters and
football pundits walked out in support
of him which meant some sports shows
were canceled at the last minute
the BBC have since announced that they
will be reviewing their social media
guidelines and that Gary will return to
presenting but what other government's
new plans and why do some people
disagree with them the government says
they will ban people who arrive in the
UK illegally from being able to claim
Asylum that means they will be detained
and removed and they won't be able to
stay in the UK in future this is because
of a big increase in the number of
people crossing the English Channel in
small boats like Arvin and his family
another story we've been looking into is
the suspected poisoning of schoolgirls
in Iran over a thousand girls appear to
have suffered mild poison attacks since
November the Iranian government has
launched an investigation and arrests
have been made some believe it's an
attempt to stop girls from going to
school and having an education
women's rights in Iran have been at the
center of attention since the death of
22 year old Master amini Masa was
arrested for apparently not wearing her
head scarf properly and later died in
police custody
her death sparked widespread protests
from women and girls with many removing
their headscarfs and solidarity and
calling for better rights for women in
Iran
well we're joined Now by Maya and Melody
who are British Iranian Nationals thank
you so much for joining us thank you for
having us so how do you feel about the
events that have been happening in Iran
recently it's really sad because from
where we're standing we're completely
powerless and we're just seeing it all
play out in front of us and we can't do
anything about it like all we can do is
watch like because we're disconnected
from our families and like The
Internet's been cut off in Iran so like
there's no way of communication with
them what do you think needs to be done
to kind of improve the situation because
we like live in a democratic country I
think with the help of social media we
can spread awareness for the women in
Iran like without voices who can't be
heard so what do you think the future
holds for women living in Iran hopefully
one day they will be able to express
themselves freely through like speech
fashion song and dance like any women
and girls should be able to really yeah
because it runs a country that has like
many like educated women as well it's
just currently because of the current
regime it's not being shown as much and
everyone deserves to have the right to
go and learn and you know be educated
and grow up to achieve whatever they
want to exactly thank you so much for
joining us today guys thank you of
course
foreign
crawling ice cream flavor a German ice
cream parlor has started selling Cricket
flavored ice cream topped with dried
brown insects the unusual ice creams are
from a shop in Rottenberg South Germany
and Cricket is not the only bizarre
flavor that owner has experimented with
his previously sold liver sausage and
Gorgons all the cheese flavor New York
so we all know that staying active and
exercising is good for our minds and our
bodies right but what if you're not into
pee or football mad like Ellie from
earlier well there are loads of
different sports that can benefit us
including martial arts and I went to
Birmingham to find out more
[Music]
did you know that there are 170 types of
martial arts Judo Jujitsu Karate Kung Fu
they're just among some of the most
popular
[Music]
martial arts is being a competitive
sport for hundreds of years but not
everybody here is necessarily taking it
up to competing competitions good work
let's go what makes you guys like it so
much it's just engaging it helps you
bring a strong mindset and focus and
discipline into your life I feel more
confident because you put your mind
antibody
to decisions for me it improves me
physically and it improves me mentally I
get to really have fun and make good
bonds with people here
nice well done what difference have you
seen with the people that have been here
from the start to where they are now
martial arts is more than just you know
learning techniques it's about Behavior
it's about the mindset the demeanor
getting some tenacity some fire in your
belly I mean you can see you've
obviously getting the results but
martial arts can be dangerous at times
but how do you teach in such a positive
but also safe way it's not about
fighting it's practiced here it's not to
be taken home or administered in school
or in your friends or on your family
it's control safe environment and to be
used wisely and respectfully
enjoy about martial arts it
great my mental health I think has
improved a lot before I was very low in
self-esteem I felt a bit depressed and
but now that I'm here I feel a lot
better
[Music]
a bit better than me but we moved
it's always great to find fun new ways
on how to stay physically and mentally
healthy football's still probably my
favorite but this is right up there
[Music]
well that's it for this week don't
forget if you have a story or want to
report for FYI head to our webpage at
first.news forward slash FYI see you
next time bye
[Music]